j'ai réservé une surprise ce soir et oui
parce que cette venue souvent mais celle
là vous l'avez jamais eu un c'est la
pire de toutes
et quelle selon du portrait chinois en
rouge flamande est une gueule
si vous étiez une injure c'est pas une
injure celle de l'âge d'une perversion
la virginité bravo une guerre recèle des
sectes une trahison
ben j'sais pas le dentiste qui me dit
toujours que ça va faire mal
c'est une arme l'humour un supplice un
supplice qu'on me demande de me taire un
poison et pokémon aa pokémon vous étiez
une [ __ ] la mort un dictateur
mon chien ça tous les jours un microbe
ya plutôt un parasite genre acariens
jour dans l'élite agréable un terroriste
a terrorist l'image je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un celi terrorisme
pour moi les artistes les gens qui font
ce métier l'image est toujours comme il
faut plaire à qui on doit plaire une
espèce de dictature donc je trouve
extrêmement pénible et lourdes voilà une
torture une torture j'ai pas être oublié
l'enfant fait chinois